The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Let's get started.
So today, I'm going to talk
a little bit more about
performance issues in
parallelization.
A little bit more out
of the [INAUDIBLE]
to what people are
doing otherwise.
So normally what we have done so
far, is we looked at Cilk.
It provides a very robust
and environment for
parallelization.
It hides many issues and
eliminates many of the
problems out there if you find
other areas of parallelization
that you deal with.
And in last lectures, we looked
at things like cache
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
algorithims, algorithmic
issues, like
looking at work and spend.
And in fact, in your projects,
you're going to use all these
nice concepts to get you a nice
parallel learning CorD.
But if you look at a lot of
these CorD [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
the very people normally for
parallelized CorD outside
probably Cilk.
And there are a lot of other
issues that arise, things like
synchronization issues
and memory issues.
Today, I think we are going to
focus mostly on memory issues.
And we are going to use open
OpenMP instead of [INAUDIBLE].
And most of these issues
will be affected on
Cilk sometimes, too.
But Cilk tries to hide
them from you.
There's a layer of abstract.
And it's hard to kind of get
to those issues in there.
So we are going to look at
this thing called OpenMP.
So today, we are going to
address things like
granularity of parallelism.
There are so many things
that just went out
on the page, I guess.
True sharing, false sharing,
load balancing issues, the
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
So from the license and keep
talking about that we want to
be out of all this not dealing
with Voodoo parameter.
Today, we actually are dealing
mainly with Voodoo.
So I guess this should
be basically
the Halloween lecture.
So we are all about Voodoo today
and see how we can deal
with Voodoo issues.
So if you look at a Cilk
program, here is a nice simple
matrix multiply, seem
to be [INAUDIBLE]
example these days.
What you can do is you can put
a Cilk formula in these two
loops and get a nice parallel
performance.
However, [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
from where how the memory
is arranged is
up to the Cilk scheduler.
Cilk scheduler is doing
some work stealing.
Depending on how the work gets
distributed, the process will
get worked, it will happen.
Hopefully, everything
will go nicely.
And so what that means is it
ties the distribution and load
balancing issues.
So it's nice if you have access
to Cilk, but many other
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] you
might not be.
And even within Cilk, some of
these issues might show up.
So what we are going
to do is step one
below the Cilk scheduler.
So there's this system
called OpenMP.
It's a more simplified
model of parallelism.
So what it tries to do is
instead of giving this very
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
system, it lets you basically
direct access to the
processors.
So what that means is there's
normally what we call a
fork-join model.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
we have with Cilk, basically.
We can do fork into different
workers and join.
And more or less, you can
actually bind these workers to
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
sometimes or make sure
that the number--
I'll give you some techniques
how to do that as I go on.
So for parallel loops, you can
do data parallelism, different
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
parallelism you can do something
like fork-join.
And you can see a bunch
of static or
dynamic scheduling policies.
So for example in OpenMP, you
can see for this loop that add
a pragma to [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
in front of this loop and
say this is OpenMP.
Parallel loop in here.
Parallel full loop
in this one.
And schedule it using
static chunk.
I will tell you what
exactly that means.
And that gives you direct access
to how each of these
parts will be run.
So let me get a little
bit in detail.
So assume you have
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] courses in
there, [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
processors.
So now in OpenMP, you are
basically opening the entire
world underneath.
And you have to kind of
see what's going on.
And if you say, schedule a
static chunk of four, assume
you have 16 iterations.
Here are my 16 iterations.
So each of these dots represent
a value for i.
So what it says is you take
chunks of four and basically
send it across it.
So what happens is the first
four iterations will go to
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] or core zero.
Next four will go to core one,
core two and core three.
So you know exactly which
iterations run where.
It's a very static thing.
You have full control
of what's going on.
Whereas in Cilk, it's
up to the scheduler.
So the nice thing here is you
can have full control.
But you get enough room
to harm yourself if
you do things wrong.
So this is a double-edged
sword in that sense.
So instead of doing static
five you do static two.
You're assigning chunks
of size two.
What it will do is it will
assign chunks of size two to
the four cores.
And then you're not done yet.
And then you start with again
core zero and assign
chunks of size two.
This is called block
cyclic schedule.
And if you do a chunk
of size one, it's
called a cyclic schedule.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] cycles just
assigning iterations to cores.
OK.
So far so good?
So I want to do something.
So I have this program.
This is again your
run-of-the-mill matrix multiply.
And I ran a sequential single
machine, and I got this
performance.
Then, I said look, I want to
parallelize the outer loop.
So I parallelize this loop.
What should I get?
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] fast or slow.
I want to just check whether
you are awake or sleep.
How do [UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
to run slower.
It's not a trick question.
This is just to make sure that
actually participate.
How do people think
it's run faster?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK.
Good.
What do others think?
OK.
They're probably checking their
email or something.
OK.
So actually it ran faster.
The source not run on the
common cloud machines.
This was a previous generation
that I ran.
So [UNINTELLIGIBLE] was
seven times faster.
So this was great.
I parallized outer loop.
What happens if I parallize
inner loop?
So this test, this i loop,
runs parallel.
Here, I launch the
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] parallel.
How much people thinks
this runs faster?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Compared
to this one.
How many people thinks
this runs slower?
OK.
There's some consistent
answers here.
Why do you think it
would run slower?
So OK.
It ran slower, so it
can improve that.
And that's a little bit slow.
Why is it slow?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
So what it's doing here, it's
basically spawning many, many
times in here.
Because every time you have
parallelism, you chunkify into
the processor.
Here you are getting a lot more
smaller chunks inside.
So let's look at how this
is basically run.
So normally, you can think about
an OpenMP program as you
have one sequential thread.
You run the main program.
And then assume you have, in
cores, you might have n minus
1 other thread just
waiting for work.
And then, when you finally
come to the parallel
loop, it says, OK.
Set up.
What do you want to run
on other basic cores.
And release it.
Release these waiting people.
And let them start working
on the parallel work.
And also, I will start doing
on my own chunk.
So suddenly, when you say
parallel four, it releases all
other cores to go run that
part of the core.
And once it's done, it's
will say, OK, I'm done.
I have to wait until
everybody is done.
So even if the main guy is done,
it has to wait until
everybody is finished.
And then, start executing the
sequence [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
So this is the gist of how
OpenMP program is run.
And if you realize that it all
heads here because you have
basically make sure all these
cases are broken up.
So there's some things that
has to be issued.
And there's a delay between
these guys can start if
everybody has equal work.
Despite not finishing on time
because it may take some time
for this to start.
And then, it has to also tell
this back OK, I am done.
So there's a lot of
synchronization going on.
Locks and unlocks.
Here it's called various
synchronization here.
And so if this work is small,
this synchronization starts
dominating.
So what happens is
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
fine grain parallelism.
Do a little work in the
parallel region, and
synchronization will basically
start dominating your time.
So how do you take this?
And sometimes when you run
something parallel, it might
even run slow because the
amount of stuff in the
parallel region is so small,
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] will start
dominating.
And that's not a good way.
And also, sometimes
you assume.
And you keep increasing
the number of cores.
Hopefully, you want to see a
nice parallelism increase, but
it doesn't, even though you
have enough information.
But that means you're running
a lot of small chunks, even
though you seem to have a lot
of parallelism available.
And also, you can make sure
the synchronization in the
time in the parallel region.
If the parallel regions
are on a very
short time, this happens.
We saw this effect when
we were doing Cilk.
Remember?
When did we see this granularity
affecting Cilk?
And what did he do?
When you write Cilk programs.
You write [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
programs.
Where did the granularity
start showing up on us?
It may not be exactly this
because the scheduling is
complicated.
OK.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: The two by two
matrix [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Something like two by--
for example, that's the reason
we wanted to have
a large base case.
Because if you didn't put a
large base case, it keeps
dividing into smaller and
smaller problems.
And if the schedule is
smart, it won't be
doing exactly this.
But it's always good to have
these large granulated chunks
at the bottom.
So how to get [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
granulated parallelism.
What we need to do is reduce the
number of [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
equations.
So you want to always try to
look for the outer most loop
you can get at all the really
large independent regions.
So you go look, and not
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
thing you want to parallelize.
You go up, up, up, up until the
point you can parallelize.
And that's the best way to
get good performance.
OK?
So if you really compare these
three programs here, again,
what you see--
of course, this has no
synchronization.
This has n amount of
synchronizations.
Here in [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
synchronization, that's
obviously a lot more
synchronization going on.
And that is where this
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] comes from.
OK.
So now, I am switching
a little bit in here.
I want you guys to look at this
program a little bit.
So what am I doing here?
I have two [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
And I am just basically adding
matrix B to matrix A. OK?
And then I have another loop
test here, adding matrix C to
matrix A. And what am
I doing in here?
I am basically going through
matrix A in another
direction in here.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: It's not really
a transpose.
I'm not transposing.
What I'm doing is I'm actually
doing a mirror because the C
gets mirrored on ix.
It's because [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
ix [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
the other direction.
OK?
So it's not really
a transpose.
So I do a mirror addition.
And then I'm asking
for the two outer
most loops to be parallel.
So if you run this
sequential--
OK, you get about 30
milliseconds, I
guess, to run in here.
So that is in [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
But if you're running parallel,
what do you get?
Should you get faster
or slower?
OK.
Anyone want to take a guess
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
Sometimes some of these
questions, you might not have
enough information to answer.
But it's still good to just take
a stand on one direction
or another.
How many people think
it runs faster?
it runs slower?
OK.
Some.
Oops.
What happened?
What happened in here?
Can anybody point out why it
might be running slower
parallely than running
sequentially?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
There's a cache issue.
Watch the possible cache
issue in here.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
If you think about, the first
equations of, I guess, the
first core--
I have some diagram.
I'll show it to you in there.
And here, only the last data
elements we'll get for the
first iterations because
we are going
in the other direction.
So if you look at it a little
more deeply into
what's going on.
Number of instructions seem
to be a little higher.
This one I couldn't actually
explain why this might be the
case in here.
If anybody has an idea,
you can say that.
But this was kind of
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
This might be [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
the cycles.
Huh.
OK.
I can explain this.
Because this is a sequential
run, this is a sum total of a
parallel run.
So because of all the overhead
that happens because this was
running on, I think, an
eight core machine.
So you're running eight times
of small companies.
There's a lot of overhead that
goes around, synchronization,
and stuff like that.
So a number of instructions
just blows up.
But for each core, you don't
have this blow up.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
Cilk?
Because does Cilk have different
processor affinity,
things that open
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]?
Because it seems like if the
program, the language--
PROFESSOR: [INAUDIBLE].
Let's see if we can process
the affinity
information or if not.
It's just pure [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
I mean if you like executed
locally if you have good cache
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
with them.
But if there's no cache
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
you might steal something
where data might
be somewhere else.
AUDIENCE: But you'll still
mimic the cache behavior,
considerably, except
for when you steal.
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So OK.
We don't have a mic in here.
OK.
There's a mic.
There we go.
But if you have two different of
these regions, the way the
parallelization happens
can be different.
AUDIENCE: In Cilk, what
happens is the code is
mimicking, for the most part,
exactly what the C or C++ code
would be doing.
And so you get exactly the same
cache hits and misses.
Except when you steal, it's
like starting over with an
empty cache.
OK?
But as long as you have
sufficient parallelism, the
steals don't occur very often.
And so therefore, you end up
getting the same kind of
behavior that you would get
out of the serial code.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
But Charles, in this one,
because you had to steal
everything here, the between
here and here, the parallelism
would be different.
AUDIENCE: There would be no
affinity between those two.
PROFESSOR: No [? affinity ?]
will be there.
Yeah, exactly.
So in the sequential one,
everything that fits in the
cache, so that would be affinity
because we are not
doing parallelism.
And that's what I think
happened here.
Because you had no
[? affinity-- ?]
AUDIENCE: No in a serial code,
there's no [? affinity. ?]
PROFESSOR: No.
Serial code-- if this fits in
the cache, it's then running
on one core.
So if it fits in the one core's
cache, you're happy.
AUDIENCE: So the issue is--
right-- is if you only access
it once, by the time you
fill up the cache--
It takes some time to fill
up the cache to get them
synchronized.
PROFESSOR: So it fits in the
one core's cache, it's OK.
Otherwise, it has no
affinity in here.
So the key difference in here
is, of course, CPI is slow.
We don't know exactly why.
But in [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
So what you find is that there's
a huge amount of cache
in [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
going on.
So that should give you a
feeling of what's going on.
So let's look at what
might happen.
So I'm showing this matches
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
last year on-- what we had were
Cagnode machines that
were basically code
to quad processor.
So we had eight codes in here.
And I put them-- you
don't have to now
look at this table.
I put them in the slides so
you can look at it later.
And so this is the last
year's machine.
And of course, this year's
machine is different.
We have two six core
processors in here.
So this is what we
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
this year.
OK.
And so right now, I'm showing
numbers for this one.
And later, I will show
what happened in the
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
So if you look at a cache--
so what happened is each of the
data items in the cache
can be in multiple states.
This is called MSI
protocol here.
What that means is the item
might be modified.
If it is modified, it can
be only in one cache.
If anybody else wants to touch
it, it has to get it out of
the modified state.
Or it can be sharing.
Sharing means it's reading.
So that means that item is
read by multiple people.
And that can have
multiple covers.
So sharing items can be
in multiple places.
However if you're modifying,
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
items in everybody else.
So that means if I modify
something, it
can only be in mine.
If other people had that
data, I had to go in
and validate this.
So if you modify this, I had
to go in and validate it.
So that's a sharing state.
That means I'm [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
everybody
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
read this.
But if I ever want to change
that, I have to go in and
validate this one.
So what that means is when I
start writing, I am validating
it from everybody.
So even if everybody kept a copy
and they start modifying,
I had to get my own copy.
And everybody else
will invalidate.
And then, if somebody else
wanted to read--
for example, if this
guy wants to read--
basically, this has
to make this a
sharing and back to sharing.
That means I have to get the
value 13, propogate it, and
this becomes sharing again.
OK.
Did you get that?
What's going on in here?
In the cache?
So reads, everybody can keep
a copy if they want.
Write-- only one guy
can keep a copy.
So what happens then
is true sharing.
So you have these two
different cores.
So I want to read something.
So I get it from outside
probably on main memory, and I
put it in my cache in here.
And then, the next guy wants
to write the same thing.
Assume I'm writing that.
And once I want to write that,
I can keep this copy I had
invalidated from here
and get a copy here.
And then, if this way, I want
to write it again, I have to
basically invalidate it from
here and get a copy.
If I'm reading, both of us can
keep a copy and just kind of
keep bouncing back and forth,
back and forth.
And so if you bounce too many
times, you get all of these
invalidations.
So the fact I looked at that I
have invalidations basically
tells me something like
this is going on.
So what's happening
in this program?
When I parallelize this four
loop, my four cores--
basically since I am doing
here [UNINTELLIGIBLE]--
are going to get this
nice distribution of
data into the caches.
Assume it fits in cache.
OK.
So all this data nicely fits
into cache, and now I'm pretty
happy when I run this one
because I got this
data into the cache.
And I write it.
But the minute I go in here,
basically this data has to
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
OK, because I am going this is n
minus i in here so this data
has a flip route.
And by doing this, basically,
I incur this huge amount of
[UNINTELLIGIBLE], and
it slows down.
OK?
So that's why it didn't
work well.
So what can you do?
When you have these read,
write and write, write
conflicts in here.
And you have to actually move
the data across in here.
And what you can do is look
for this true sharing.
You can look at the
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
and see if we have excessive
[UNINTELLIGIBLE], we have a problem.
And how do we eliminate that?
You want to make the
sharing minimal.
If you want to get some data
into a cache, you want to try
to keep it there as
much as possible.
And if you're using, you'd
want to try to align
everything across.
So even across different
regions, it'll use the same
kind of things.
And/or enforce some kind of
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] technique to
keep the data alive.
So there are a lot of techniques
in there, but true
sharing can be an interesting
problem.
So in here, simple
change, yes.
You're, basically, instead of
changing A, you change C. So
you write A the same way.
But now what I have done is
I am doing the mirror by
changing the axis to C, is to
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] is the same
as this axis.
So these two are
the same thing.
And the minute I
do that, voila!
I get good speed up.
Because if you look at that, my
inundations has gone down.
My L1 cache [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
has now
really, really gone down.
I'm not doing anything.
And of course, I am doing more
instructions here than this
one because--
I think, the difference between
instruction here and
here is because a lot of times
synchronization operations are
dynamic because in the
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
miscounted as the instructions,
you are busy
waiting in there.
So this number is not really
a constant number.
OK, question.
AUDIENCE: Not a question.
So another thing one could do
here is do loop fusion.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Yes.
Here is a nice way of putting
both of the loops into one and
do loop fusion.
And that works.
In this case, you can do that.
AUDIENCE: So loop fusion is
where you take two loops, and
you convert it into one loop.
So in this case, you could have
just written one nest,
which has two things
going on inside.
And then you would save all
the loop overhead and the
scheduling overhead.
So rather than doing it twice,
you actually have reduced the
overhead to just the parallelism
of the one loop.
So if you look at that, you'll
realize that you could somehow
make it just be a single nest
with two statements in there,
rather than one.
PROFESSOR: So basically, instead
of [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
entire thing and move plus
C into here, basically.
And I could have just done
it in one loop nest.
That's what loop fusion
would do here.
So we can actually
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
much nicer in here.
But just for example purposes,
so now I really reduced this
one and got that.
So this is great.
Cagnodes really showed
this classic
problem in the computer.
And so I'm like, OK.
Now we have new machines.
Let's try it and see
what happens.
What does this show?
This is your nice cloud machines
we've got now.
I have no slow down.
I was really disappointed
because beforehand, I had this
for sharing going on
in here and had a
really big slow down.
But this one, in fact, the
difference is very small.
And when you look at any kind of
performance counters, they
are pretty comparable.
There's nothing much
going on here.
So what do you think is
going on in this new
architecture now?
Why this might be?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: That's an interesting
observation, but
also we have--
yes, core seven basically is
two by two in the die.
But we also have two different
processors.
So that's there, too.
So in some sense, when you
get our two-way process
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
So that's there.
That might help.
That's an interesting
observation.
What else might be
going on here?
Why do you think they manage
to get this one?
What might be another answer?
What can hide these kind of
delays that can happen?
Load delays, and cache misses,
and stuff like that.
What techniques and hardware
can hide those?
Just [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
a speculation.
Prefetching.
So most hardware has an
internal mechanism.
When you start fetching
data, you say, aha!
I see a pattern.
I know you want to
get this thing.
Let me go forward and bring more
data, thinking you are
going to follow that pattern.
OK.
All or most of the
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
for, I think, have
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] even a
Pentium had something for
prefetching going on.
But most of the time, what
happens is the prefetching
engine can't keep up.
If you are getting there,
it's [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
a little bit further.
You are going to catch up, and
you're going to start because
you have more [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
here.
I think [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
has a really, really
good prefetcher.
And then, we saw it in our
architecture slides, too.
That a lot of things that used
to happen before is gone.
So this is really good.
What that means is a lot of
weird stuff that's going on
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
making them disappear.
So these kind of problems
don't show up.
So that's the nice story.
The other part is, OK.
Now if you start really tweaking
your programs to one
architecture, you wait
a generation.
And then now, we have done
either the tweaking--
the best case, tweaking has
no impact, and it's
not affecting anything.
In most of the time, worst case,
tweaking actually slows
down the program because you
are trying to do something
complicated.
That's just not needed
anymore.
So even though these kind
of things showed up in
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
architecture, it's
not an issue.
But if you go to many of the
smaller architectures that
have that don't have that
much of the very popular
prefetchers, this kind of
issue you would see.
So for example, if you go to a
cell phone [UNINTELLIGIBLE],
you would probably see these
kind of issues happening.
Any questions here so far?
So that's the good news.
You guys don't have to worry
about it too much.
But at least it's good to know
the technique because you'll
see it in other architectures.
So now, I want to switch a
little bit into looking at
programs that don't have what
we call data parallelism.
That means you can start and
say, [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
parallels.
Everybody get the different
chunk and run.
And we are going a little bit
more deeply into looking at
programs that are a little
bit different.
So I wanted to come up with this
little representation to
represent the program.
And so if you think about
iteration space--
actually before you, I'll
go down to dependence.
I'll also do a little
bit of load balance.
So here's a loop that
in my iterations--
the first one I transformed
zero to eight.
But J only runs from
one to eight.
So each I, I have less
and less amount of
J iterations, basically.
OK?
It's a triangular loop.
OK.
So this is the way to represent
iteration space, so
I will represent data and
get back to this again.
So if you look at a data space,
you can assume data
iteration space could be this
funky, triangular, hyperplane
type of thing.
Whereas data is mostly
[? rectangulineum ?],
multi-dimensional rectangle.
So for example, if I have
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
and it's a one-dimensional
one, this is basically a
two-dimensional data.
And you can have
three-dimensional cubes and
stuff like that.
You can represent
data like that.
So this is a way to
nicely represent.
And when you start thinking
about it, we can look at
what's going on.
OK?
So now you have this
loop again.
So here's the basic
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] iterations.
And here's the data.
Assume this is both A and B.
There will be another one for
matrix [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
B. One data into each iteration
is going to touch.
So these are the data that
need to get touched, and
here's the iterations you
are going to run.
So we can say OpenMP
parallel four.
So what happens when you
do parallel four?
So I am going to get parallel.
And so core one gets this one,
another core, another core,
another core get these
iterations running.
So what happens if
you do this one?
Do you get really good
performance?
Why?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: It's not balanced.
The load is not balanced
in here.
So basically if you run
sequential and if you run
block distribution, I get about
3x performance in here.
So if I look at closely, here
is the number of iterations
given to each core.
The first core gets almost
nothing, and the last guy gets
a lot of work.
Here's where something like the
Cilk runtime can come into
play because with Cilk runtime,
basically, this guy
will finish the [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
start stealing from
somebody else.
And so it would be
done nicely.
But whereas if you do a
static schedule, you
are in this big bind.
You don't have too many
things going on.
And basically, this is what
we call load imbalance.
So what you can do is figure out
a complicated partitioning
so you can statically
partition this out.
Or you can do something like the
dynamic scheduler like the
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
scheduler for a solution.
So how to detect
load imbalance?
Basically, what you might want
to do is for each of the
different sections you are
running, you want to look at
the time mistakes.
And in the [UNINTELLIGIBLE] axis
varying, huge varying,
that means there's a load
imbalance going on.
So you might want to check and
make sure each of the parallel
regions time is taking.
And that gives you this view.
How to eliminate load imbalance
or the use of
dynamic scheduler that
will deal with that.
Or you can do a different
distribution statically.
That will not partition
in this large block.
So let me show you a static part
because we have already
learned the dynamic
part before.
So now instead of doing that,
we do a cyclic distribution.
We use a static one.
That means if you have a lot
more than and a little bit
better distribution so what
happens to the processor?
Zero gets this one
and this one.
One gets this one
So on and so forth.
So that would be a little bit
between balancing there.
But if you have enough of
cyclic, the imbalance would be
much lower.
So should we run faster?
So here's the iterations
each guy gets in here.
This looks very balanced because
I had a lot more
iterations than this
eight one.
This is not that balanced here
because this guy gets a lot
more than the first one.
The first one gets six.
And the second and last
one gets a lot more.
Uh oh.
What do you think is
happening here now?
I ran again slower.
See I guess the people in class
last year had things
worse because they had this
old processor that did all
these crazy things on them.
and you guys get the fast one
that doesn't do that.
So why do you think cyclic
distribution is
running a lot slower?
What might be going?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Spoiling
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] it's not that
much because if you don't run
this and synchronize, what you
do is you run the same amount of
tread and say, now, instead
of running continuously, you
run jumping all iterations.
You should run zero and nine
or whatever jump over
iterations.
Why do you think?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, there's
a cache issue.
All this time and the question
is not sure, it's probably a
cache issue.
What type of cache issue do
you think is going on?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
But let me show you
what happens.
So you get off then.
OK, so if you look at--
the data is here so let's
look at what happens.
So this is running a
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] lower.
It's showing a lot more
instructions, but instruction
doesn't tell you too much
because a lot of them might be
missing synchronization
costs in here.
So instruction is not that
illuminating here.
The big illumination here
is this one again.
Invalidations.
I have a huge amount of
invalidations going on.
So here is a case of
false sharing.
So what happens is now things
next to each other, you want
to multiply different
processors.
We're not touching
the same data.
Everybody's looking at
somebody else's data.
So what happens is assume I want
to write this data item.
I like that data item.
But I get the entire cache line
because when I ask for
that, I get my synchronization
by the cache line.
I get this entire cache line
coming in here into this one.
And the next guys
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] at me.
This core won't write this
data because instead of
blocks, I basically
give each strips.
There's a lot of overlap
between strips.
So this guy says not to write
this one, I had to get the
entire cache line
going back here.
And so if you want to write that
again, I had to get the
entire cache line going back
even though we are writing
different data.
Because we are sharing
cache lines in here.
This thinking was in back
and forth, back and
forth, back and forth.
I have a lot of cache
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
Things are really shot.
OK?
And so what happens here is if
you look at the cache lines--
there's my animation.
So cache lines basically
mess this all up.
You can see that really
carefully.
What happens is between these
lines, there would be some
overlap of cache lines.
And this overlap in cache lines
keeps bouncing back and
forth, back and forth in here.
And so what happens is basically
cache lines are
bigger than the data size, or
there's overlap in here, and
the cache line is shared when
the data is not shared.
And so how to detect false
sharing in too many conflicts.
You assume this is a nice
parallelism, but suddenly, you
don't have a speed up, and you
have a lot of conflicts here,
even though there isn't
something to be sharing.
And how to eliminate
false sharing.
Make data used by each
contiguous in memory.
That's a good way
of doing that.
Or pad at the end.
So these kind of at the corners,
there's not going to
be any overlapping.
So in here, one thing you can
do is, you can measure each
thing that each of
the cores get.
We can make [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
But before what happens was
a core used to get this
line and this line.
There are different
places in memory.
But you can make these two
contiguous in memory by
basically now, instead of
having a two-dimensional
array, you made that a
three-dimensional or disarrays.
AUDIENCE: Can you
say that again?
PROFESSOR: So before you what
just happened was each of them
were going to get this line
and this line, each core.
All these lines that were in
different parts of the memory.
In here, each would get
only two lines.
But they're in a different
place.
So if you have more cyclic,
you'll get a lot more lines or
lower memory.
So what we can do is we
can arrange the cache.
So if you think about this, you
can think the cache, now
the data, is instead of
two-dimensions is
three-dimensional data.
One dimension is this
cyclic part in here.
So we can do that.
And then, you can change any way
that the cyclic part, the
one that I got this line and
this line, now become
contiguous.
So you think about data
as a two-dimension.
You think about it as a cube.
And you kind of change the cube
for the inner dimension
to be the one that's
contiguous.
So you can do data
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
transformation and get there.
So now what happens is the role
of core zero just gets
contiguous in memory.
And core one gets contiguous
in memory.
So if you're trying to make it
contiguous, that's great.
So between padding and making
things contiguous, you can get
good performance.
And if you do data
transformation, voila!
My invalidations just went
down drastically.
I again have a nice load
balancing here.
Invalidations went
down drastically.
That means my [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
increased a little bit and I
get really nice speed up.
So here are the kind of crazy
things you are to do if you
are doing things like
algorithms that
are not cache obvious.
And if you are doing directly
parallizing yourself without
letting a nice [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
time to help you.
Something like a
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] assistant.
So I'm just going to
summarize this
because this is important.
We looked at a bunch
of cache issues.
We looked at cold missiles,
capacity missiles, and
conflict missiles before.
And today, here are
some examples of
true sharing missiles.
What happened was I am actually
really using data,
but I set up my parallelism
in such a way that between
different executions, my data
has to move across.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
So I am truly sharing data,
but the data has to go to
somebody else's cache.
So I've got a lot of
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
violations here.
More into this one is more like
false sharing, where you
assume there's no sharing, nice
parallelism, everything,
except the program
runs very slow.
And that can be because
of false sharing.
So we just kind of touch
on these two topics.
OK?
So let me switch gears a little
bit about dependences.
We touched on the dependences
a little bit.
And these are two fine
programs that are not
completely parallel.
So normally, what happens is a
true dependence means that I'm
writing and reading
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
other way out.
And if two guys are both
fighting, then the order has
to maintiain us out would
be dependence.
And did our dependence
even loop, because
these are single items.
So if you have an error here,
this is becoming a lot more
complicated.
Because there's no simple
thing in here.
Because it's not just using
the same iteration.
You might be using data from
different iterations.
So what happens is there's
a dynamic instance of
iterations.
So one iteration writes the
data, and somebody else might
be reading the data.
And that is basically
the order we have to
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
Let me give you an example.
This kind of demonstrates
what's going on.
OK?
And when you edit, you say
look, this is where you
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
complicated.
So in order to give you
and example, let me
look at this program.
I have a simple program here.
Ai equals Ai plus one.
My iterations--
I'm running five iterations
in here.
So this is my iteration space.
I have a large array, so
this is my data space.
And now, I keep running
this program.
So what happens is this is
time going down in here.
So the first situation
basically, I first read and
then write.
Same in the second iteration,
I read and write.
Third iteration read
and write.
Fourth iteration,
read and write.
Do you see how this is going
on these four situations?
Second iteration, third
iteration, fourth iteration,
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
OK.
So what happens is first
iteration read
this value is zero.
And write the value as zero
in the menu writing.
Second iteration A1,
A1, A2, A2, A3, A3.
So now, when this is writing,
that's a dependence
between these two.
You see the true and entire
output dependence
between these two.
What type of dependence
do we have?
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] dependence.
True dependence is what?
What to what?
What's the first thing
that occurs?
What's the next thing
Anybody want to answer?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Write to read.
So you have the first thing
has to be write to read.
Watch this.
This is a read to write.
So what type of dependence
is this?
This is anti-dependent.
So here is ante-dependence
in here.
But the nice thing about that is
this dependent didn't cross
the iteration boundary.
So these black lines are my
iteration boundaries.
So these are for situations
that [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
So there's no iteration
crossing in here.
You can kind of [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
it using each
of these iterations and my
dependencies within the very
same iteration.
So the same iteration I have
dependency [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
OK?
This is a simpler case.
So let's look at something a
little bit more complicated.
So I have Ai plus 1
equals Ai plus 1.
So what happens is first
I am reading Ai.
And then, I am writing Ai plus
1 in the same iteration.
The next iteration, I
am reading now Ai
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
this is A0 and 1.
This is A is 1.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
I am writing Ai plus 1.
I am writing 2.
So I have a dependence
like this now.
What type of dependence
is this?
This is a true dependence
because I am writing.
And this is actually reading
what what it is writing.
So does this look parallel?
No.
Because what happens is if you
look at each iteration depends
on the previous iteration.
So you have to actually have
this dependence going back and
forth, back and forth in here.
So let's look at a couple
more other things.
So here is Ai equals
Ai plus 2.
So I am basically reading
So I am reading this one.
I am writing this one.
Reading this one.
Writing this one.
Here is my dependence
that's in here.
You see the two are
anti in here.
This is anti-dependence because
I am going from a
reading to a write in here.
Can this loop be parallel?
Can this loop run parallel?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So can every
iteration run parallel?
There could be basically.
No because what happens is if
you look at that, there's a
dependence that goes
like this.
And of course, there
are two chains.
So if you are interested, you
can run at least two-way
parallelism.
You can run one chain parallel
to another chain when you do
get that much parallelism.
How about this one?
2i and 2i plus 1.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
Is there independence in here?
Nope because one is--
you are reading all the elements
and even writing
elements [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
dependence.
So you can have a missing
parallel.
OK?
So this is the kind of
interesting thing
that is going on.
So next, I want to look at
something a little bit more
complicated.
So let's look at this.
So here's a classic algorithm
called successive over
relaxation.
So it kind of simulates a lot of
times things like heat flow
through a plane.
So the idea there is--
let me illustrate
what he does.
So assume you have a
big metal sheet.
And you put some kind of heat
source in one place.
And after sometime, it all
reaches a steady state.
The other side might be cold.
And you want to know part of
the sheet's temperature.
Because temperature
can leak out.
And there are more things like
you have a heat source and
others that [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
to work a glass of water or
some kind of a sink.
So what is the heat
distribution?
So one way to compare that this
is basically the same
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
The heat value here is basically
the average around
all these other values
right now.
Because if something is too
hot, the heat is going to
propagate something
that is too cold.
The heat is going to propagate
because it kind of has to be
average around that.
Then, you take the
average in here.
So what it's doing
is calculating
the average in here.
And then, you have to do
it many, many times.
So if you have a heat source,
at that point, it
would be very hard.
And then, it will start
propagating slowly and kind of
propagate down.
And the cold side in this way
or after running many times,
it basically stabilizes.
And at that point, you have the
kind of heat distribution
that we [UNINTELLIGIBLE] have.
This is the kind of calculation
you do.
So this is the calculation.
So what you're doing is
calculating this.
You are creating this,
this, this, and this
and updating that.
And then, you do it
for t time stamps.
So you just go around doing each
of these things first and
doing it for t time stamps.
OK?
So we would like to
run this parallel.
So here's my basically
data space.
There's my data items.
So here's my array,
two-dimensional array.
So this is how I'm
trying to update.
I'm reading all this file.
So here's my iteration space.
So what I have looked at this.
I don't want to--
it's hard to give you
a 3D diagram.
I don't have a 3D projector.
So what I'm showing here is
three-dimension here.
So this is the previous
iteration, first iteration.
So if I still go tij.
So you go through t, and then
you go through i in here, and
then, when you're done, you
go to the [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
iteration and you go this way.
So here's how you
would iterate.
So you run this one, this one,
this one, this one, this one,
this one, this one, this
one, this one.
And then increase t by
1, and go like this.
And right now, we are here.
We are trying to update
this one.
That's what we are
trying to do.
And that means we are already
finished up to this point.
All these points are
finished up.
Now, what we have to do is
figure out when I'm reading,
who actually wrote this value.
OK?
First of all, let's figure out
which iterations might be able
to write this value.
So if you look at
this value, this
relationship in between here.
This one, basically, is ij.
And this is ij, ij, ij.
These three iterations
can write this one.
So and these iterations
Let me go to this one.
This is a pretty darn
complicated [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
So what that means is in
this one, this one
already wrote something.
This is what I'm reading
in here.
This one already wrote
something.
This is what I'm reading here.
This iteration wrote
something.
I read it here.
OK.
Everybody following so far?
How about this, guys?
Who wrote the value I am reading
in these iterations?
In this one, I haven't
reached there yet.
So who has written that?
So I assume this
is t equals 1.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
somebody has to write
those things.
So what that means is this also
wrote all of those values
because I have done
those iterations.
But the interesting thing is
some of these values got
overwritten.
This value got overwritten ,
this value got overwritten.
So these two values disappear.
This value got overwritten
by this guy.
OK.
But we haven't overwritten this
value, this value, and
this value yet.
This one, basically,
I've just updated.
But I [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
this one.
Do you see this?
Is everybody following me?
AUDIENCE: Once again, sir.
I got lost.
So what are [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So what happens is I
am trying to update in this
iteration because this array
get rid of multiple times.
But in each iteration, you are
only doing one update.
So I am trying to read
and write in here.
So I need to read all
of these five
elements in this iteration.
So I want to figure out
who wrote that.
OK?
This one can be written by this
guy and this iteration.
Could this iteration write
its value in here?
OK?
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
This iteration write because
we see it's writing ij.
I mean my diagram is not that
great because I have three in
here and five in here.
So just bear with me on that.
So assume I am writing
ij in here.
So my iterations go from 1 to n,
but my data goes from 0 to
n plus 1, basically.
1 to n minus 1 iterations.
0 to n plus 1 data.
So data is bigger than iteration
space because of
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
So what happens is when I'm in
this iteration, we'll say this
is 1 2 iteration.
I will write this value.
This iteration will also
write this value.
OK?
You see that?
All of these iterations
are the same.
This iteration we will also
write this value.
But right now, who is the
last guy who wrote it?
The last guy that wrote
it is this guy.
Because this iteration wrote
it, and after that, it got
ordered in this one.
But this one hadn't occurred
yet, so it hadn't been ordered
by this guy.
So the last guy who wrote
it was this one.
So that's why I had
to eliminate this.
But this data value--
I haven't executed this
iteration yet.
So nobody had written this
one in this time stamp.
So it has to be from the
previous time stamp.
So I read two values from the
current time stamp, three
values from the previous
time stamp.
These three values have
to come from the
previous time stamp.
These two values that come from
the current time stamp.
You see that?
OK.
Good.
So what that means is because
dependence means--
OK.
This line, this dark, red line.
See.
I am reading a value in a
current iteration that was
written by this iteration.
So that means I have no
dependence between these two
iterations.
OK.
This line, this dark,
red line.
I am reading a value written
by this iteration.
So I have a dependency
in here.
This line means I have a
dependence between this
iteration to the current one.
This line means I have
dependence between this
iteration and the current one.
This line means I have
dependence between this
iteration and the current one.
You see that?
OK.
So now, I want to see how we
can parallelize this group.
So what can I do?
So I look at all this
dependence.
At this point, I don't have to
think about all this where who
wrote what.
I can say this is dependence.
In order to do this equation,
all these iterations have to
be done because I am losing the
values produced by them.
So these have to be finished
before I can patch that.
So the parallelism
means I tried to
do things in parallel.
So can we parallelize
this loop?
Can we run each time
stamp separately?
No because I am using these
three values from the previous
time stamp.
So I can't run this time stamp,
B equals 1, until B
equals 0 is done.
Or B plus 2 [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
B plus 1 is done.
OK?
So I can't parallelize
this loop.
OK.
Can I parallelize this loop?
Why?
Will dependence stop me from
parallelizing this one?
So I'm looking at i.
This is my i dimension.
How many lines, at
least, tell me.
How many dependencies
are going to stop
me from doing that?
OK.
Good.
I have [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
Somebody says three.
Somebody says one.
OK.
Let's get a vote.
How many people think
it's three?
OK.
There's one vote for three.
How many people think
it's three?
it's one?
Wait a minute.
One vote for three and
two votes for one?
OK.
Where's the rest?
For two?
For 0?
Can't be 0 if the
0 is parallel.
OK.
So we'll start parallelizing.
So what happens in here?
Right now, this is
actually one.
This one.
Because these things don't
participate because this has
already happened.
When you go to ij iterations,
these are already done.
So you're going from t.
So you're looking at the current
iterations because
you're ending in two loops.
So the t is done.
So these all are already
done when you go try
to parallelize sides.
So I don't have to worry
about these three.
In here because actually I'm
losing t of something here, I
am in trouble.
So when you go look at this
one, I have this one.
So every dimension has
a dependence in here.
So I can't run it in parallel.
So does this mean that there's
no parallelism?
Who think there's
Who thinks there is?
Oh, somebody thinks there's
no parallelism.
Who thinks there's
parallelism?
OK.
More people think there's
parallelism.
Let's see what we can do.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Do you really
think [INAUDIBLE]
I'm trying to figure out
how to word this.
Do you really want to have
dependence on the same concept?
[INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
I mean you can do--
this is the way this SOR
is sitting so there's a
dependence between time stamp.
There's another SOR.
What they do is kind
of a red, black.
So when you calculate the next
time stamp, you calculate it
right and complete
the new array.
So there's no dependence.
So that's a different
algorithm.
This algorithm, basically,
uses sum value from
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] because the
value-- the algorithm you're
talking-- you already created
the other copies.
You had two copies.
You're bouncing back
and forth.
Nice.
No real problem in here.
But then you had to have twice
the amount of storage.
Here, you are updating in.
And since this is kind of
running enough iterations
until it converges, it doesn't
seem to matter that the
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE].
OK.
So we cannot find a loop,
what we call doall loop.
The doall loop means there's no
loop carried dependences.
It's fully parallel.
This is the best case.
So what happens is when
you get there,
everybody can run parallel.
And when you're done, you can
stop and then do that.
So this is the doall loop.
Of course, there's
no doall loop.
We can look at every
dimension.
We had some kind
of dependence.
So there's another choice, what
we call doacross loop.
What that means is we have some
loop carried dependence.
There's something I
have to use for
the previous iteration.
But it's only one thing.
I have a lot of other things I
can run around that only I
just have to wait one thing.
One is done.
I can just keep running.
And if I calculate and send this
one early, then I can do
my other calculations later.
This is not that great.
If you look at the
difference here.
This definitely has very little
overhead in here.
This can run slow.
And of course, this thing
gets produced very late.
It's [? almost ?] sequential.
So I hope you can just-- it the
other guy wants something,
I can immediately send
it very early.
And then I can run there.
So you can get some kind of
doacross patterns in here.
So if you want to
do this one--
this is a little bit
crazy in here.
But they'll do it in here.
And so what first we are to
do is you are to say, OK.
Look.
I'm running this loop, the
i loop in parallel.
But I have to exchange
some data.
Before I want to run this one,
I have to basically get the
previous i value produced.
And when it's done, I can say
the next guy can use it.
So this is a very
complicated one.
I don't want you to understand
it too well.
So the reason I put it is to
show that OK, if you want to
spend a week trying to really
call this up and understand
and make sure that
it works OK.
So you can do things
like that.
OK?
Aha.
So this is the true
voodooness.
OK.
AUDIENCE: So in Cilk, if you
do this with divide and
conquer, you can make it be what
I called in the Tableau
construction.
Each layer here is basically
constructing a Tableau.
And so if you do it with divide
and conquer, you can do
it with a very simple
recursive code.
But you can also do it with a
loop that goes diagonally.
AUDIENCE: [INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR: Yes.
I'm going to get that.
That's next.
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
PROFESSOR: That's OK.
So the reason that I'm showing
that is because this class is
not just about how to make the
cores exactly run faster.
Think about algorithmic issues
and stuff like that.
So sometimes, when you look at
a problem, it looks crazy.
And there might be some changes
you can do that you
can get to run things
in parallel.
So I'm actually doing
not diagonal.
I'm actually doing something
very simple.
So what I have done here
is I have all these
dependences in here.
OK?
So the problem here is I can't
find a single [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
that basically has
no crossing.
But if you look at this
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
diagonal here.
What you see is, in fact,
there's nothing that crosses
the diagonal.
OK?
So this one basically
doesn't depend on
this one or this one.
It only depends on
the previous one.
So I can run everything in
the diagonal parallel in
here in this one.
So of course, I can't write
anything [UNINTELLIGIBLE] in
here, but there's a cute
trick you can do.
What you can do is you
can take iteration
space and skew it.
So what I have done is now
instead off the same thing,
instead of this being a square,
now I skewed it a
little bit.
OK?
So what that means is when I'm
running first i, I basically
don't run any here.
Then, I run this one and
this iteration here.
So what I have done is I have
kind of moved my iteration
space around.
Do you see how this might be?
So now, the interesting thing
is when I skew, if I look at
this line, I can parallelize
in this one because all the
dependences come from the
previous iteration.
Am I right?
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
Yeah.
I skewed it.
Yes, everything in here, these
ones are parallel.
OK?
And any dependence comes from
the previous iteration.
There's no current iteration
in here.
Everything in this
one is parallel.
So I can parallelize this.
So this one doesn't depend
on this one or this one.
So this is all parallel.
This is a little bit
more complicated.
So if you're interested
to go deep, just go
stare at the slides.
I have the slides out there to
understand how that happens.
So if you think about what I'm
running here in parallel is
the one basically this
diagonal in here.
So what happens is if you run
this, this, and this parallel,
there's no dependence.
I don't need this one or this
one to run this one.
So I can run this, this,
this, this, all
this diagonal in parallel.
But the trouble with just the
diagonal is I don't have a
place in here to say
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
for a diagonal.
So I basically skewed
it and then made a
diagonal into one loop.
So then, now what happens
is basically j
loop I can run parallel.
This one.
So I can do it four
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] four.
OK?
So here's something you found
a problem that has no nice
parallelism.
But you realize there's kind of
a what you call a wavefront
going on here.
Wave going on here.
So not the given dimension, but
there's another dimension
that you can parallel.
So you kind of skewed your
space to get that nice
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] line.
And you run parallel.
So that's all I have for today.